i'm here at six the clark county school
district will soon be deciding whether
or not to keep
superintendent dr jesus jarrah now this
follows criticism by state lawmakers and
some school unions
regarding comments made at the special
session eight news now reporter kristen
drummond has the latest
ccsd controversy and i think it's
selfish i think they're doing it for
personal reasons i'm glad to see some
accountability at the top
mixed reactions regarding this letter
signed by trustee danielle ford to
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
it asks to review his performance next
week during a special meeting
a request about a month after the
superintendent's evaluation with board
members
what happened in 30 days that
you want to fire him the letter states a
lack of trust in his leadership
and his alleged failure to maintain a
professional relationship with the
governor
and lawmakers trustees plan to consider
his character
misconduct or competence do you worry
that the trustees
may terminate him um a little bit yeah
i think that it would leave this you
know the shift that is ccsd adrift
without a captain and
the hardest time i think in education
that we can really fathom
the clark county education association
calls the effort by trustees
reckless and driven by a political
agenda a statement released thursday
says in part
there is a back story and we welcome the
discussion and will bring to light what
has been conveniently left
out i have some assumptions about what
it may be about
trustee lola brooks tells me there is no
precedence for this situation and
they're figuring it out
trustee daniel ford and i scheduled a
virtual interview for this morning
but she canceled last minute and claims
an attorney advised her not to speak
in the newsroom kristen drummond 8 news
now
we can also tell you that the special
meeting is scheduled for wednesday at 1
pm
is is expected to be virtual and we'll
have more details for you if you'd like
to watch it from home